PROFESSOR: So B
strong field Zeeman.
So what did we say we would do?
We would have H0 plus e
over 2mc B Lz plus 2Lz
B. This would be our
H0 check I call it,
plus delta H fine structure 1.
And we said what
we have to do now
is strong field Zeeman is more
important than fine structure.
So we first have to
get the strong field
Zeeman figured out, with
the bare bones hydrogen
atom, what it does.
And then on those states, we
will do perturbation theory
for fine splitting.
So it is redoing fine splitting.
And you say oh my
god, that's hard.
We spent a whole
lecture doing that.
Well, second time you do
things, they go a little faster.
So it's not that bad.
But here there is
something quite remarkable.
This was supposed to be
your known Hamiltonian.
And you say no, it's not known.
I never solved this before.
On the other hand, when
we had H0 plus delta
H1, a fine structure,
we did struggle.
And we found those states--
approximate states.
Here the situation happily
is surprisingly simple.
And one reason for
that is the following.
That again, perhaps
your initial impression
this can be solved exactly.
You don't even need perturbation
theory to add this term.
What?
Yes!
This Hamiltonian
commutes with H0.
Isn't that right?
H0 is rotational invariant.
So it commutes with any j.
Uncertain H0 has
nothing for a spin.
It's a one matrix there.
So this commutes
with Hamiltonian.
So it's possible that you can
diagonalize this completely.
Simultaneous-- eigenstates
of the first part
and the second part, so
simultaneous eigenstates
from all of those!
But the news is even better.
Your uncoupled states--
uncoupled states n, l, m, l,
m, s, those were eigenstates
except eigenstates of H0,
the all good ole hydrogen atom.
But actually they are
exact eigenstates of lZ,
and exact eigenstates of sz.
So they're exact eigenstate
of the Zeeman Hamiltonian.
So they state are it.
These are the exact
states of H0 hat!
These are exact eigenstates--
eigenstates of H0 check--
I'm sorry.
Its was not hat with
eigenenergies as follows.
There are no mystery,
the eigenenergies,
they're very simple.
The eigenenergies are
e, n, l, ml, l, m, s.
Exact are e, m, 0, the ones
that the hydrogen atom has
that don't depend on any of
these other things plus eB
over 2mc eh bar B
over 2mc ml plus 2ms.
So this serves perfectly the
name of known Hamiltonian.
That was not the
case for weak Zeeman.
And weak Zeeman who had this
one and this one, and the other
was the approximately
known Hamiltonian, to which
we added the weak Zeeman.
Here, it's this perfectly
known Hamiltonian, to which we
have to now add fine structure.
So maybe the last
thing that helps
you visualize what's
going on is to understand
what happens to the splittings.
Because you're going to have
to fine structure splitting.
And fine structure again,
you will have to ask,
can I use non- degenerate
perturbation theory or can
I not use it?
So you need to know what
happened with the degeneracies
after you add this term.
Are all that the degeneracies
of the hydrogen atom
broken by this term,
or do some survive?
If they survive, is
fine splitting diagonal
in those degenerate
subspaces or not?
So the most important
thing is figuring out
what are the degenerates spaces
after you've added this term.
This is intuitively
what you have to do.
If you approach this
problem OK, I now
have to compute fine
structure on a new basis,
and you have no idea
what the new basis is,
you are proceeding a little
bit with your eyes covered.
You should always try to make
things a little more concrete.
So look at the n equal 2 states.
You have l equals
0 and l equals 1.
Here, you have six states.
Remember, their spin.
There's two states here.
The two states of l
equals 0 have ms equal 1/2
and ms equal to minus 1/2.
So they're going to split.
This number is going to be
either plus 1 or minus 1,
and they're going to split.
And here-- so this is plus 1 on
this factor here, this number,
or minus 1 for that number.
For this states of l
equals 1, ml for example,
can be 1, and ms plus 1/2--
so 1 plus 1 is 2.
So there is a state of 2.
Ml equals minus 2 minus
1, and this minus 1/2
gives you minus 2.
So that's another state.
You can have more states.
For example, if you take
ml equals 1 and ms equals
2 minus 1/2, you get the 0.
But you can also have ml equals
minus 1 and this plus 1/2--
plus 1/2, which
also gives you 0.
So here there's a degeneracy.
There are six states.
You will see that there
is one here and one there.
So here is the nature
of the degeneracy.
The six states have
split like that.
There's a degeneracy
across l multiplets.
And there's a degeneracy
within l multiplets.
So two types of degeneracy.
And that's what you will
have to consider when you
think of the fine splitting.
In fact, the problem
in the homework
gives you some sort of trickery
to evaluate this expectation
value with a little less work
than the traditional method,
but still asks the
question whether you
can use the generator or
non-degenerate perturbation
theory.
And that's an
interesting question.
And this example, can help you
visualize a little better what
kind of degeneracies you have.
OK, we're concluding a chapter
in the history of [INAUDIBLE]
six.
We're done with
perturbation theory,
and we're done with hydrogen
atom for the moment.